[Musique]
deux savonnettes un tube de dentifrice
par personne et par an une brosse pour
trois personnes 22% seulement d'hommes
qui font une toilette quotidienne et 38
% de femmes
voilà quelques-uns des chiffres d'un
sondage qui nous accusent parait-il de
ne pas être très regardant nous français
sur notre hygiène corporelle et qui nous
placent loin derrière les anglais les
suisses bien sûr et les allemands jeu
mais vous l'avez heureusement vous
l'avez combien de fois par semaine huit
jours huit faux imad là le soir ou le
matin le soir temps en temps
il faillit slave par semaine on va les
tuer les jours tous les matins le soir
et on se brosse les dents avant de
manger et après manger et vous madame
ah oui bien sûr les jeunes il en faut
beaucoup dans la vie bien sûr et leurs
propos on sait que c'est aux parents ou
à l'école d'éduquer à l'hygiène je crois
que c'est aux deux endroits
aussi bien l'école que comparant est ce
que vous leur avez appris et vous à vos
enfants à faire quoi tous les jours
enfin tous les jours d'abord on stoppe
les mains et puis on se lave aussi les
dents donc surtout les dents et puis
alors bien sûr les mains et les tenir
toujours propre et les roues avant le
fait que ce soit nécessaire h pas que
j'aime pourquoi parce que ça me détend
déjà au premier lieu en plus un bon
moyen de s'isoler je trouve la salle de
bain qu'est-ce qui salit le plus les
cheveux de pieux est ce que vous l'avez
une plus le cheveu n'ont pas bronché
pour fait pas attention et ma voix le
mot enid on voit aussi un coup de pub
mais n'entre pourtant toujours
tu m'en sors
prenez des douches souvent mois aux
attentes en forme à l'école
quand toujours tous les soirs relu
autres propres
moi oui c'est notre moi c'est tous les
jours mais toujours d'être de droite ont
prié pour moi c'est naturel
madame qu est ce qu on vous réclame le
plus dans ses rayons moins de savon et
plus de parfums mois notamment plus de
parfois c'est ça oui c'est vrai on lui
donne rendez de rang shampoing shampoing
aussi
il vous arrive d'avoir dû l'âge très
très salsa à lui et du sorgho raid et
des chaussettes j'avais des cheveux et
des vêtements même des vêtements qu'on
porte le jour qui soit très simple
puisqu'il ils sont vraiment brillant
tellement un sage donc pas changer tous
les jours grâce à ça il y en a qui
changent pas tous les jours on serge
diop nous voulons créer des vêtements
ils allaient apporter leur donne six
mois est-ce que niveau de vie influe sur
le degré de propreté
j'ai cru pendant un certain temps que le
niveau de vie avait une influence mais
je me rends compte que quel qu'il soit
on trouve des familles entières qui ne
savent pas se brosser les dents et c'est
un phénomène familial on en recense une
mauvaise transmission et depuis le début
de votre carrière il ya quand même une
évolution dans un sens positif
alors je pense que
le travail de motivation des confrères
peut-être des médias fait qu'on se
brosse certainement mieux les dents elle
à tel point que même on voit des gens
qui se brossent les dents avec excès et
qui qui se font des lésions
parce qu ils se branchent trop mais
c'est très rare
[Musique]